who joins me now live from Pocono and
Danica I'm going to get to the racing in
just a second but first I'd like to turn
right really quickly if I can and can
you sell me on why I should start doing
yoga for your mind it can be hard for
your body but for your mind it's really
hard okay good it's good yeah just of
that so if you ever feel like you need
more confidence or peace yoga
all right good I'll start trying to find
my energy as I follow you on Instagram
and your most recent post took a little
bravery and a great photographer as you
point out but your quote you could to
make a leap of life or work you have to
be brave and stay positive how do you
Danika apply that philosophy in your
career well a lot of this time things
that I write on social media are things
that I am actively working on so I'm not
going to say I've mastered anything or
I'm really really good at that but these
are all things that I remind myself of
when you're whenever you want to do
something great you have to you have to
stay positive for you know your own
confidence and as well as to create this
world around you that's good and it
brings good people into it and they want
to be in it if you're negative then I
feel like it just pushes those people
out so and you got to have goals right
you got to be brave and you got to be
willing to jump and then that will
appear so it's just it's I feel like I
try and do these things myself so if
anyone else has advice for me I'd be
happy to take that too I feel like you
turn it into a great life coach it's a
great read every day when we catch up
with you on Instagram we just mentioned
a second ago yeah today both the
qualifying and the race take place so
how does that change your normal
preparation definitely discombobulates
race day a little bit but you know this
is this is how it used to be in the
Xfinity series we would qualify and race
on the same day now it went a lot
quicker and I think it was like one that
qualifying then and we'd have half a
distance of a race but today we'll we'll
get it all done in one day and it makes
all the race day meet and greets and an
hour of qualifying format and then a
race that's really long all put into one
seem a little overwhelming but the race
starts a little later
so everything is well spread out and
most of all it's going to give us two
day weekend this is worked out so this
world of NASCAR we we get two weekends
off out of 40 in nine months so it's
it's exciting for all of us to think we
might be able to have a Saturday Sunday
show here and there and then we jam in a
stupid live interview on sports that are
just to make your schedule even better
these are the things we move mountains
for this is this is not a problem okay
good because you are on a run of three
straight top 15 finishes where is your
team at right now you know I feel like
we were all positive and I feel like
we're communicating well I guess
honestly I've had I had a lot of really
unfortunate luck earlier in the year and
should have had more top tens or 15
throughout the year for sure so I really
knew in my heart that the luck was going
to shift it was going to change it had
to it couldn't keep going like it was
and I feel like it's finally doing some
of that but it came from just you know
not letting those weekend get to us and
being positive like I talked about
earlier yeah I mentioned a second ago it
looks like you're going to have to get a
win to make the playoffs so let's take
Pocono out of it for a second what track
do you believe in your mind gives you
that best opportunity well I mean I
don't think you can take pokin a lot of
it because Pocono is one of those unique
tracks that if we aren't the fastest car
and on the lead strategy leading it then
we can try something different and so
any track that we can pit and not go a
lap down creates a unique strategy
because let's say if I pit and then the
yellow comes out right afterwards and
everyone else hasn't pitted yet then I
jump through the lead so it creates some
unique strategies so you can't take it
out of it but - I'm not going to lie I
have I don't even know where we're going
to walk in Sun neck that's another one
that's another one that you can have
some different strategies and like Road
course racing um qualified six at Sonoma
last month and was a recipient of some
bad end of luck but but you know that's
a place that it might be able to happen
identica we're pulling for you I know
you've got a busy schedule
appreciate your time this morning on
SportsCenter and because you're my new
life coach I'm going to sign off of the
mountain namaste
so thank you namaste
all right Danica take care Danica
Patrick was live on sports that are
still ahead on the program